AINSLEY: WE ARE BACK WITH THIS
FOX NEWS ALERT.
KIM JONG UN IS IN GRAVE DANGER,
REPORTS THIS MORNING THE NORTH
KOREAN LEADER IS IN CRITICAL
CONDITION AFTER HEART SURGERY.
STEVE: RUMORS HAVE BEEN SWIRLING
ABOUT THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR’S HEALTH EVER SINCE HE
HAD A PROCEDURE AND AFTER HE
MISSED THIS CELEBRATION FOR HIS
GRANDFATHER’S BIRTHDAY LAST
WEEK.
NOW THOSE RUMORS ARE REPORTEDLY
ON THE RADAR OF U.S.
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
BRIAN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HE WAS LAST SEEN AT A MEETING 10
DAYS AGO.
SOUTH KOREA’S GOVERNMENT PUSHING
BACK AING IT HAS NOT SEEN
ANYTHING USUAL OUT OF THE NORTH.
FOX SOURCES SAY THE WHITE HOUSE
IS AWARE OF THE REPORTS.
BUT CAN’T CONFIRM HIS CONDITION.
LET’S SEE IF WE CAN GET THE
ANSWER FROM ROBERT O’BRIEN.
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
ROBERT, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LET ME ASK YOU, WHAT COULD YOU
TELL US ABOUT KIM JONG UN.
SOUTH KOREA NO PROBLEM OR THE
REST OF THE WORLD THAT THERE IS?
>> WELL, WE ARE MONITORING THESE
REPORTS VERY CLOSELY.
AS YOU KNOW, NORTH KOREA IS A
VERY CLOSED SOCIETY.
THERE IS NOT A FREE PRESS THERE.
THINGS THEY PROVIDE INCLUDING
MANY THINGS INCLUDING THE HEALTH
OF KIM JONG UN.
WE ARE MONITORING THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS CLOSELY.
PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A GREAT INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THE PRESIDENT, THE VICE
PRESIDENT, SECRETARY POMPEO,
SECRETARY ESPER.
GENERAL MEALY.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WATCH MEN ON
THE TOWERS DURING THESE THIS
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS MAKING SURE
THAT AMERICA IS SAFE.
WHETHER IT’S FROM THE VIRUS OR
FROM ADVERSARIES ABROAD.
SO WE’RE KEEPING A CLOSE EYE ON
DEVELOPMENTS IN NORTH KOREA AS
WE ARE WITH OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD.
AINSLEY: AMBASSADOR, COULD YOU
TELL US WHY THE PRESIDENT
DECIDED TO SIGN THIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER?
HE SAYS HE GOING TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND IMMIGRATION.
>> LOOK, WE ARE TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING.
THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING CAN HE TO PUT THE
HEALTH OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST IN THIS CRISIS.
THIS IS ONE STEP.
IT’S NOT DISSIMILAR TO THE
RESTRICTIONS ON TRAVEL FROM
CHINA THAT HE IMPLEMENTED BACK
ON JANUARY 29TH.
AT THE VERY OUTSET OF THIS
PUBLIC CRISIS.
WE THINK THAT THAT -- THOSE
RESTRICTIONS SAVE SAVED
THOUSANDS OR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF LIVES.
THEY WERE CRITICIZED AT THE
TIME.
ONE CANDIDATE.
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID IT WAS
XENOPHOBIC.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO BE
GUIDED BY POLITICS HERE.
IS HE GOING TO BE GUIDED-I DO
WHAT’S BEST FOR THE HEALTH OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STEVE: SURE, AMBASSADOR, OF
COURSE, THIS IS JUST AS THE
BANNER SAYS BELOW US, IT IS A
TEMPORARY SUSPENSION OF
IMMIGRATION.
AND WE KNOW THAT FEDERAL STATUTE
DOES GIVE HIM THE AUTHORITY IN
CASES OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
ALTHOUGH IT IS UNPRECEDENTED.
BACK IN THE 1918 PANDEMIC WITH
THE FLU, I THINK THE UNITED
STATES STILL ALLOWED IN 100,000
PEOPLE.
SO, WE GET THE PART ABOUT HOW
IT’S TRYING TO STEM THE TIDE OF
INCOMING INFECTIONS.
BUT, AT THE SAME TIME, THE
PRESIDENT IN HIS TWEET,
AMBASSADOR, MADE IT CLEAR THAT
THIS WAS ALSO ABOUT SAFEGUARDING
AMERICAN JOBS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK RIGHT NOW AND THEY
NEED JOBS.
>> WELL, THIS VIRUS CAME TO OUR
SHORES FROM OVERSEAS.
SADLY.
AND NOT ONLY HAS IT AFFECTED THE
HEALTH AND CAUSED THE DEATH OF
MANY AMERICANS IN OUR HEARTS AND
PRAYER GOES OUT TO THOSE WHO
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE SICK
OR STRUGGLING WHO HAVE LOSTED
LOVED ONES.
AND I WAS WATCHING THE INTERVIEW
THATYOU DID WITH LIAM HELPING WI
FIRST RESPONDERS.
DOCTORS AND NURSES.
CUSTODIAL STAFF ON FRONT LINES
KEEPING THE HOSPITALS FREE FROM
INFECTION.
DOING A GREAT JOB.
THERE HAS BEEN AN ECONOMIC COST.
PRESIDENT IS LOOKING OUT FOR
AMERICANS ON BOTH FRONTS AT
EVERY TURN.
BRIAN: OBVIOUSLY THERE IS A BIG
PUSH TO FIND OUT WHAT CHINA KNEW
AND WHY WE STILL DON’T KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING WE NEED TO
GET IN THERE AND LOOK AROUND AND
FIND OUT WHERE THIS ALL STARTED
WHERE IT WAS THE WUHAN LAB OR
ACTUALLY IN THE WET MARKET WHICH
MYSTERIOUSLY HAS REOPENED.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT COMPLIMENTED
THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA EARLY.
WALLS IT BECAUSE HE WAS UNDER
A -- UNDER THE ALLUSION THAT HE
WAS GETTING ALL ACCURATE AND THE
FULL STORY ABOUT THIS VIRUS?
AND DOES HE REGRET THOSE
COMPLIMENTS THAT HE THREW AT
PRESIDENT XI.
>> NO THE PRESIDENT IS ALWAYS
VERY EXRIMENT TRI IN HIS
DEALINGS WITH THE FOREIGN
LEADERS.
IF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN BE ON
THE PHONE CALLS THAT HE HAS WITH
OUR ADVERSARIES AND FRIENDS IS
HE A REAL COMMITTEE.
HE WAS THE SAME WITH PRESIDENT
XI.
HE WAS CLEAR FROM THE OUTSET WE
NEED TO GET THE CDC INTO CHINA
THERE IS A HUGE BURDEN ON CHINA
TO TELL US WHERE THIS CAME FROM.
DID IT COME FROM A LAB?
DID IT COME FROM A WET MARKET?
NEITHER OF THOSE ARE GOOD
ANSWERS.
RIGHT?
THESE WET MARKS ARE OUR ---
BRIAN: IT’S INCUMBENT ON THEM.
ROBERT, DON’T YOU BELIEF IT’S
NOT SOMETHING THEY ARE OBLIGATED
TO DO IT AND THEY STILL HAVEN’T
DONE IT.
AND I’M JUST WONDERING WHEN ARE
WE GOING TO GET PUNITIVE WITH
THEM AND WHY ARE WE JUST
CONTINUING TO PUT THE ANALYSIS
HAT ON AND WE DON’T GET MORE
AGGRESSIVE WITH THEM TO COME
CLEAN ONCE AND FOR ALL?
>> WELL, I THINK WE ARE BEING
PRETTY TOUGH ON CHINA.
THERE ARE LAWSUITS BEEN FILED BY
FOLKS OUT THERE.
SOME FOLKS ARE LOOKING HOW TO
DEAL WITH CHINA GOING FORWARD.
WE CERTAINLY ARE REMEMBER, THIS
IS THE FOURTH OR FIFTH PLAGUE
COME OUT OF CHINA SINCE 2,000.
AVIAN FLU, SARS, H1N1.
WHETHER THESE ARE COMING OUT OF
LABS THAT HAVE SLOPPY
PROCEDURES.
WHETHER THEY’RE COMING OUT OF
WET MARKETS THAT ARE REALLY
HORRIFIC IF YOU WATCH SOME OF
THOSE THINGS.
WE HAVE GOT TO STOP.
THIS WE HAVE TO STOP THE EXPORT
OF THESE VIRUSES FROM CHINA.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE OUR
POSITION AND WE HAVE MADE OUR
POSITION ON THESE ISSUES VERY
CLEAR TO THE CHINESE.
I THINK IT’S BECOMING A
WORLDWIDE CALL NOW THAT CHINA
HAS TO COME FORWARD WITH THE
INFORMATION.
I MEAN, IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
HOW THEY HAVE HANDLED THE VIRUS
WITH THE WHISTLEBLOWERS
DISAPPEARING AND NEWS MEN AND
WOMEN FROM THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" AND "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEING KICKED OUT OF THE COUNTRY,
AND YOU CONTRAST THAT TO HOW
TIJUANA OR SINGAPORE OR OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE HANDLED THIS.
THERE IS JUST A REAL BIG
DISPARITY THERE AND WE HAVE TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
AINSLEY: AMBASSADOR, HOW DO WE
DO THAT HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
WHEN THEY COVER THINGS UP.
THEY ARE GETTING RID OF THE
WHIBS, YOU KNOW WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT N. THAT
LAB AND FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED
IF IT REALLY DID START THERE.
HOW DO YOU DO THIS?
HOW DO YOU INVESTIGATE CHINA?
>> WELL, WE HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS
IN OUR TOOL KIT.
ONE OF THE THINGS I KNOW AND I
THINK THERE ARE AMERICANS -- I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE LAWSUITS
THAT ARE BEING FILED HERE
AGAINST CHINA.
AINSLEY: YEAH, CLASS ACTION.
>> WE WILL SEE HOW IT ALL PLAYS
OUT.
SOME OF THESE TRIAL LAWYERS,
THEY ARE PRETTY DOGGED AND THE
CHINESE HAVE A LOT OF ASSETS
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT RIGHT NOW WHAT WE ARE DOING
IS CALLING ON THE CHINESE TO
COOPERATE AND WE WANT TO GET
ALONG WITH CHINA.
WE HAVE A TRADE DEAL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO GET ALONG WITH
CHINA.
BUT CHINA NEEDS TO BEHAVE IN A
FASHION THAT MAKES THEM
RESPONSIBLE PLAYER IN THE WORLD.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, WITH THE
OFFSET OF THIS VIRUS IT WASN’T
GREAT.
THEY HAVE GOT TO FIX THAT.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.
AMBASSADOR ROBERT O’BRIEN HAS A
GREAT OP-ED, THE PAGES OF THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
CHECK IT OUT IF YOU GET THE
PAPER OR ONLINE.
SIR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US FROM THE NORTH LAWN.
IT LOOKS LIKE A NICE DAY IN D.C.